[Music]
with Philadelphia it's a beautiful day
to [ __ ] be alive
look at me I belong by the [ __ ]
dumpster that's the story of my life on
a smoked weed you got a smoke we buy the
[ __ ] dumpster
we'll look at the sun's out the birds
are chirping
and I'm doing my thing coast of [ __ ]
coast it don't matter
you know me guys let's do this right
here there you go who's [ __ ] better
than you
transmitted live from [ __ ]
Philadelphia
a global Skywalker little Joey from
perennial I'm waiting for a [ __ ] rat
to pop out of this goddamn dump standing
minute now
don't matter
let's Friday you're done for the week
you washed you [ __ ] and you're out
bang it out tonight you understand
they're like a [ __ ] savage uncle Joey
representing tenth planet [ __ ] Omaha
Nebraska in the house [ __ ]
imagine walking around Philadelphia to
[ __ ] Nebraska [ __ ] on that takes [ __ ]
balls
[Music]
but bucket that's how we do it people
they got two shows tonight this so done
you got two tomorrow night they're
[ __ ] sold out too so you gonna wait
to see me in that way with the party and
jump out a [ __ ] window
I'm [ __ ] stoked to the gills I got up
about 8:00 this morning the guys walk
around the neighborhood cut the [ __ ]
nice [ __ ] walk understand it melted
some fat my [ __ ] stuff like that that
Iranians
[Music]
and his breakfast they took enamel I
wrote a little bit now I'm gonna [ __ ]
write more maybe throw some weights
around burn some more this [ __ ] fat
off my body and I said kind of suck
because it's Friday you get your dicks
up and your ball flick if not join
Scientology that's not what you wanted
over here [ __ ] Ivan cops
well his growth it's down to the Nook
this is gonna Roach kicks right here
for you little [ __ ] half of [ __ ]
employ your roaches away any
professional always Congrats why the
filter is for [ __ ] amateurs I've been
telling you that [ __ ] the brooch is the
[ __ ] head of debt when you go to hell
with the same smoke big joints [ __ ] no
they smoke the roaches
see that
like a [ __ ] mule in cakes with us
it's down to the [ __ ] centimeter
you like joy but your fingers are
burning yet but I could break into a
[ __ ] safe and let me fingerprints
that's how I roll
fingerprints on me left 20 [ __ ] years
ago ain't got no fingerprints if you're
a real reefer smoking doing a finger
prints you burn right through the
[ __ ] middle I don't give a [ __ ] who
it is the FBI the Dean they can't
[ __ ] figure out what happened to this
kid's finger
look at that let's go koala [ __ ]
clouds of debt and I supplement this
with the [ __ ] paper time you know I
think the paper kind of more
I took a little coffee a little vapor
plant a nicotine gum whose feathers
[ __ ] you
but the display is new couple look at
the size
people going by and Facebook macaws
[Music]
look at this little [ __ ] up
understand be feet that's a professional
the rest you can suck my dick and call
me shorty I was born in 1940 but I love
you we had a good week on the podcast
don't forgive you stop with the [ __ ]
horn [ __ ]
anyway got a good week you didn't
download Mondays and Sundays or whatever
[ __ ] get doing and that's it I get no
surgery I'm in Vegas July 11 I get no
surgery on the 11th to [ __ ] take the
dead coke rocks out of here from the 80s
we tell you some whatever they take out
of my nose ever the solid [ __ ] it's got
to be worth the half a mil and my nose
from old coke rocks and [ __ ] pubic
hairs and God knows what I got man
that's blocking my [ __ ] airwaves but
as usual you know I love your mother
[ __ ] we're all my heart you think I
do this without him do a foot high
school all [ __ ] day roost
bathtubs I came out here I found the
location because I don't have miss you
[ __ ] yeah I'm saying permission
I truly miss you from the bottom man
ain't one of these [ __ ] hope you
don't father [ __ ] you know we'll just
say that mission
when I mission mission I want to see you
[ __ ] so tomorrow night I found
this fight I'll be out in a bar by 39 so
get ready to get high with Uncle joy
tomorrow warm and I'll let you guys know
that you know we got a nice little tango
so you're like Joey you don't stop
mourning it [ __ ] up my dance with a
gun one more horn on the [ __ ] takes a
rap rap and put it all in [ __ ] gas
tanks they won't be mourning or driving
nowhere you don't know that trick get
back to me I love you [ __ ] boy
didn't get my mother like bingo and
beard I said it byah all right don't
forget about me I'll see you guys
tomorrow and bright no he's sparkling
like a [ __ ] Saint